Ranger halter felt the bark of the tree
trunk slamming into his back practically
knocking all the air out of his lungs as
he tried desperately to slow his frantic
breathing the sound of his own panting
filled him with a sudden horrifying
thought if he could hear his own ragged
breaths then it could hear them too he
clamped a hand over his mouth clenching
his jaw shut so tightly that he thought
his teeth might Splinter as he pushed
them together his freehand gripped the
tranquilizer gun shuddering as the snap
of a twig rang out somewhere behind him
it had caught up to him already he could
bolt make a quick dash for a cover
behind another tree but it was close
enough now that it would see him and if
it did it would come rushing after him
with a speed that even a seasoned park
ranger couldn't match as much as he
tried to force himself to stay still the
Petrified curiosity got the better of
him Holter peeked out from behind the
tree and immediately wished
it had all started out as what sounded
like an everyday occurrence High atop
his watchtower in the Glacier National
Park Ranger Holter had been enjoying the
view of Montana's Rocky Mountains a cup
of coffee from his thermos in his hand
then the familiar squawk of His Radio
had cut short his appreciation of the
Serene scenery Halter's side tossing the
remaining contents of the cup over the
tower's railing wondering what kind of
day he was in for as he went to answer
the radio most of the time things in
Glacier Park were as peaceful as they
looked but the park ranger knew that
staying Vigilant could make all the
difference when it came to finding a
missing hiker in time or the difference
between deterring a group of campers
away from a family of bears and having a
hell of a mess to clean up he pushed
down on the button for the microphone
connected to the bulky radio that took
up practically an entire desk halter
thank God came to relieve voice from the
other side we've been trying to reach
everyone put them on alert we've got
trouble reports of a coyote gone feral
attacking folks I'm on it Holter replied
grabbing his gear from the cramped
Watchtower as he continued to speak into
the mic where did the report come in
from not far from your station I'd say
about a click West from your position
stowing his tranquilizer gun Ranger
holder descended the ladder from his
Watchtower down to ground level as a
park ranger holder valued the
environment he worked in and as a fan of
the SCP Universe we know how much you
value intricate World building or in
some cases World destroying but either
way we couldn't be happier to introduce
you to the sponsor of today's video
World Anvil World Anvil is a
comprehensive set of World building
tools that not only help you craft and
organize your unique setting but also
present it in a captivating manner from
wikileike articles and interactive maps
to a full-fledged RPG campaign manager
and novel writing software World Anvil
has everything a World creator could
dream of world Anvil equips you with
over 25 templates prompting you to dive
deeper into your Creations enrich your
content by embedding Maps images sound
effects and even little C for that
immersive touch with their Innovative
design you can easily visualize your
world through Maps Chronicle its history
with timelines and fine-tune events with
intricate details your crafted world can
be beautifully showcased on a unique
homepage inviting others to dive into
your vision got us an idea while working
on another no problem World Anvil lets
you swiftly create new articles or link
existing ones ensuring you never lose
track of your inspiration but my
personal favorite feature is their
interactive maps Beyond just creating
and uploading your own designs you can
directly link your Creations allowing
for a dynamic and engaging experience
and if you're collaborating invite your
team to refine write and even let your
fans chip in I'm currently working on my
own interactive map of site 17 and maybe
I'll even let you see it when I'm done
but don't wait for me dive into World
Anvil yourself and elevate your world
building game and here's a treat use our
Link in the description to go to
worldanvil.com and use the code SCP to
grab a whopping 51 off any yearly
subscription explore create and share
with World Anvil the sun was already
starting to dip out of sight behind the
trees pretty soon it'd be pitch black
save for the beam of his flashlight he
had to move fast coyotes were only known
to attack humans on rare occasions
usually they kept away at least enough
to make them a minimal risk but waiting
for him just west of the Watchtower
wasn't a coyote at least not at first
watching it from behind the tree moments
later Ranger holds her stomach turned at
the sight of the creature it walked by
petally like a human but the shape was
all wrong its legs looked broken but
that hadn't stopped it from catching up
instead of bending at the knee they were
z-shaped pointing back behind the
creature then twisting back again in the
opposite direction at the Joint they
looked more like the legs of a dog but
they were far too big the same could be
said of the arms bent out of shape at
multiple points like its legs were the
creature was a mess of misshapen
the cartilage in its ears had seemingly
reformed into points and there were
claws protruding from its fingertips
practically bursting out from where a
human's fingernails would be but beneath
it all and what alarmed Ranger halter
the most was its skin it had darkened in
patches layers of fur sprouting over
those areas but there were still parts
that remained clear or skin human skin
was still visible peeling away to reveal
the new fur coated layer underneath it
looked like a grotesque accident like
something ripped straight out of an old
horror movie the kind of monster that a
mad scientist would make by haphazardly
splicing DNA and playing God holder
checked the tranquilizer gun in his
trembling fingers still empty after that
most recent shot he reached for another
Dart slowly sliding it into the loading
mechanism and readying the pistol it
cocked and made a sound the creature's
malformed head turned snapping directly
towards the source of the noise directly
towards halter he turned to Sprint away
trying to expand the distance between
him and it if he was too close the dart
wouldn't have enough momentum when he
pulled the trigger the tova's boot
snagged on something solid unmoving a
route from the tree he'd been hiding
behind he felt himself tumble Landing
with a hard thought against the forest
floor his gun it had fallen from his
grasp he scrabbled around in the dirt
for it barely able to see where the
tranquilizer had landed in the dark just
as his fingertips brushed past something
metal halter felt the force of something
heavy strike his back again this time
though it wasn't a tree it was the
creature it snarled gnashing its Canon
Jaws that were protruding out of its
skull rows of sharp teeth that had
uprooted the old ones bearing themselves
into the park ranger's neck and not
letting go until he'd stopped moving for
good a few short hours later a convoy of
mysterious unmarked Vehicles arrived at
Glacier National Park the rest of the
park rangers who had reported range
activity were approached by shadowy
figures who refused to give their names
or offer up any form of identification
other than just referring to themselves
as experts in things like this not long
after none of the others would remember
Ranger Holter or the incident that had
led to his untimely death after
administering amnestics it didn't take
the SCP Foundation search party long to
discover a lone coyote sniffing around
the remains of a park ranger covered in
blood the wild animal was captured to be
brought back for testing before being
re-released into the wild meanwhile the
foundation scoured the rest of the area
until they came across the real culprit
standing in a clearing a short distance
from a footpath through the forest was
scp-1579 of course the next challenge
was getting it packed up and transported
to biosite 66 without touching it to the
untrained
iscp-1579 looks to be fairly unassuming
even as far as anomalous objects go it
is simply an old wooden sculpture the
kind that can even be occasionally found
in various wooded areas throughout the
world its age is Apparent from even one
cursory glance at
scp-1579 the partial damage to its Cedar
surface speaking to the numerous years
it has existed for along with the bright
green moss that covers it although
curiously this Moss doesn't seem to dry
out and die in responses to changes in
humidity nor does it affect
scp-1579's structural Integrity as for
where it came from and who made it those
are still unknown as if the answer to
what holds
scp-1579's anomalous properties whether
or not the cedar it was carved from or
the Moss coating the sculpture possesses
some unknown Properties or if scp-1579
was somehow imbued with these after
being created initial testing by the SCP
foundation's researchers determined as
cp-1579 to have an abnormally High
resist to the type of damaged wood and
particularly Cedarwood is susceptible to
for one it does not seem to show any
signs of rotting or natural degradation
for another it is also resistant to heat
at least to a certain extent it doesn't
burn the same way other objects
constructed from Cedar Wood however this
sculpture is not entirely indestructible
pieces can be easily chipped off of the
main body of scp-1579 and these
splintered fragments continue to carry
the same anomalous effects as the rest
of the sculpture even when separate from
it but of course you want to know about
the creature how does this supposedly
harmless if a little structurally
abnormal Cedar Wood sculpture connects
to whatever it was that killed park
ranger halter well it's quite simple
actually
scp-1579 killed Holter not directly you
understand but by proxy through its
further anomalous properties still
confused well then how about a
demonstration frustration let's take a
look of one of the foundation's
preferred test subjects an Expendable
member of d-class personnel probably
spending multiple life sentences working
here at the SCP Foundation rather than
behind the bars of a maximum security
institution now what would happen if you
place this delightful individual in the
same room as
scp-1579 well nothing initially that is
until the subject touches the Cedarwood
surface of the sculpture either out of
curiosity or following the instructions
of a foundation researcher that's when
the real anomaly starts the wooden
sculpture will exhibit a slight but
observable movement shuddering slightly
as if moved by an unseen Force this will
precede the person who touched the
object feeling a burning sensation that
kind of irritating painful heat that
spreads underneath the surface of the
skin the burning will always begin at
the area of their body that made direct
contact with scp-1579
and touching it again at any point will
trigger a reactivation of the
sculpture's anomalous effects subjects
experiencing the effects of scp-1579
have described the feeling as being akin
to a bad sunburn that rapidly spreads
Across the Skin from the point of
contact only to stop once it has
affected a person's entire body
following the subsidience of the burning
sensation subjects experiencing the side
effects of touching a cp-1579 will
notice an immediate change to Their Skin
Within a window of three minutes their
skin becomes thin and paper-like in its
texture before starting to peel away
once this stage occurs the peeling skin
will reveal a new layer underneath hence
the colloquially used code name for this
anomaly different skin however this
so-called different skin isn't merely a
new layer of otherwise ordinary human
skin instead it will belong to another
species entirely a person coming into
contact with scp-1579 will find
themselves rapidly developing new skin
that shares the physical traits as well
as matching DNA to that of a number of
animal species it should be noted that
these features will continue to rapidly
develop until the subject is entirely
transformed and is no longer considered
to qualify as a human being as for the
specific transformation that occurs
there are a number of known outcomes
that repeat in the following cycle let's
say our d-class we'll call them subject
a touched as CP 1579 at the start of the
cycle they would after the burning
sensation stops and peeling begins start
to sprout dark feathers across their
torso arms and upper legs likely with a
great deal of pain as the sharp Quill of
these feathers start to burst out from
beneath the skin beneath the knees
subject a will see their legs start to
become yellow and scaly as well as a
change that causes their toenails to
Simply start to painfully protrude
outwards until they form pointed
blackened Talons subject a face will
also start to grow feathers however
these grow outwards away from the areas
of the nose and mouth flight feathers
will also protrude from the forearms
multiplying in number until their entire
body is covered at which point subject a
on every level including genetically
more closely resembles a corvus corax
more commonly known as the common raven
than a human being anymore take another
test subject subject B and get them to
touch
scp-1579 right after their different
skin is covered in brown fur that's
approximately four inches long their
lips and skin underneath the fur will
darken and their nose will become
constantly moist claws will start to
grow from their fingertips although
these will be notably smaller than those
of a fully grown creature of the same
species an ursus arctos horubilis or a
grizzly bear then we get to the point in
the cycle where some unwitting hiker
encountered
scp-1579 in the forests of Glacier
National Park Montana when this subject
subject C touched the cedar sculpture
their skin began to grow layered fur as
the cartilage of their ears is separated
from their tissue and replaced by new
reshaped cartilage much like subject B
who scp-1579 turned into a grizzly bear
subject C also had darkened skin a
moistened nose and longer sharper Nails
it was at some point during this
transformation that an unassuming park
ranger stumbled upon subject C
frightened by what he saw this Ranger
was unable to identify that what he
interpreted as attacks by some kind of
half human half animal hybrid were
actually desperate pleas for help as
subject C was transformed into a coyote
although it's hard to say which
physiological change triggered by
scp-1579 is the most alarming or
unpleasant to experience The Fourth Kind
is in no way any more pleasant than the
preceding three in the cycle subject D
of this particular series of tests will
find the new layer of skin that emerges
under the old to be hairless and of a
green coloration often with brown
markings unlike the previous instances
their skin will rapidly begin to dry out
and seems to be far more reactive to the
humidity of the surrounding environment
it is also far thinner than that of the
skin possessed by other Transformations
that
scp-1579 causes so thin in fact that the
eyeballs of subject D will be visible
through its eyelids which rapidly become
translucent similar to those of the
suracris regula otherwise known as the
Pacific Tree Frog repeated activation of
scp-1579's anomalous properties will
trigger the next transformation in the
cycle whether the Cedarwood sculpture is
touched by a new subject or repeatedly
by the same person in the latter
instance where a subject is re-exposed
to
scp-1579 the additional changes their
body undergoes will be significantly
more painful they're already newly
replaced outer layer of skin will fail
to dry out and will begin bleeding
instead three or four consecutive
exposures to scp-1579 will lead to
excessive bodily trauma for the subject
usually causing them to die from shock
before the fourth transformation is
complete and as we're sure you can
imagine an amalgamation of a human a
raven a grizzly bear a coyote and a tree
frog is hardly a pleasant sight this
unfortunate fate was suffered during one
of the first incidents with scp-1579
that brought the foundation's attention
to it during an elementary school field
trip a teacher who was explaining the
history of totem poles in Native
American culture accidentally touched
scp-1579 while experiencing the pain of
her transformation she fell against the
sculpture in a panic not realizing it
had been what caused her to change this
repeated triggering of the object's
anomalous effects led to her untimely
death an event that had to be wiped from
the minds of her students by the
foundation using the careful application
of Class B amnestics for now SCP 1579 is
kept in a secure sterile environment at
a foundation storage Warehouse where
Personnel are not permitted to make any
contact with it so there's no need to
worry about accidentally running into
scp-1579 in the wild although there are
always plenty of other things to worry
about while out on a hike through the
forest things that could be right behind
you now check out SCP-173 the sculpture
and scp-1897 human domestication Society
for more